the minimalists are once again going on
tour this is our tenth tour in ten years
it is called the les Coast tour will be
hitting eight cities across the west
coast of the United States and Canada
for more details head on over to the
minimalists comm slash tour we'll see
you soon
Oh Eric you mentioned air pods a second
ago oh yeah I was gonna ask him to okay
so what do you think about air pods man
are they are they are they gonna give us
brain cancer
well I've been using my less ever since
Josh sent me an article but I still use
them every once in a while really been
wanting an Apple watch we were talking
about this earlier and I still haven't
gotten one even though I really liked it
can monitor ECG and I can just load my
podcasts or audiobooks up onto that and
have a smaller interface and less to
carry around my phone the warning label
on it says to keep it at least 10
millimeters from your skull from the
face because like Apple knows the
biological impact of radio frequency and
Shore cell and Wi-Fi signals are a
little bit more damaging in terms of
their power and the ability to that
frequency to impact tissue or you know
in your pocket to lower sperm quality or
anything else that these things have
been shown to do but there are a few
studies that you can find on PubMed that
show an impact of bluetooth on cell
membranes particularly class one
Bluetooth which a lot of these devices
emit and if the Bluetooth can be
disabled such as say you know I'm
wearing a self quantification ring right
now as are you Josh is this aura ring
then yeah you can go to your app and and
put it into into airplane mode and keep
the Bluetooth off but considering that
the ear pods do not have a Bluetooth
function that can be disabled that would
defeat the purpose of them being
wireless headphones and they're in your
ears next to your brain yeah I am still
that guy with the old school iPod
shuffle just continue in what 2015 or
sometimes it's there man yeah connected
to it to it you know an old school pair
of headphones I've got like six of those
shuffles because they're so hard to get
nowadays and and
you know they're kind of increasingly
difficult to sync and I I don't know how
much longer it'll be before almost every
listening device requires you to have
bluetooth headphones but I have seen
enough evidence that those radio
frequencies Bluetooth signals Wi-Fi cell
frequencies etc are damaging to biology
that I play it's aiso not worth it so
let me ask you carrying the cell phone
around in your pocket like because this
makes me think like I Mariah and I
eventually like my wife and I will
eventually have kids we've been talking
about maybe you like trying here in the
next year or two I'm thinking about just
putting my phone on airplane mode and
then like scheduling maybe once every
hour or two to take it off airplane mode
but I mean would that would that help me
significantly like with the the harmful
effects that that stuff can cause like
is that is that a good solution so I
will usually have the Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth turned off okay regardless of
course I absolutely need it the phone
itself should be an airplane mode if
it's on your body and even if not you
know for example I have a fanny pack I
wear it's kind of like a Kevlar RFID
enabled fanny pack it's called a pack
safe and usually my phone is in that if
it is not in airplane mode and I'm
carrying around because I'm expecting a
call or I'm talking on it and in
addition to that it's inside of what is
called the defender shield case which
blocks some of the RF from being emitted
by the phone not all of it but some of
it so at the at least I would have a
something like a like a RF blocking case
okay good to know good to know all right
so no more air pods but they're worse
it's annoying and they're very
convenient I had
you